most
business friendly countries in
the world okay if we look at the most
business friendly countries in the world
uh kai do you have a number on which one
it is
is the wikipedia one that one okay so
the easiest countries in the world to do
business in by the way look at this
every year they've been number one
except for 16 15 they were second
it said i'd love to before you say it
yeah poll the audience who they think
the most business friend maybe someone
who gets everybody up though
it's already up guys great job great job
everybody it's all right
but they can't see that screen though
yeah maybe they can take a look at that
they can see it they can so by the way
look at this
singapore was number one for like 10
years straight do you see that
you see the singapore run and now it's
been new zealand the last four years so
it's a dark fight between two people
new zealand new zealand and who was the
other one with that that
uh yes really only two people and hong
kong is you know
top three top four there's nothing
denmark
south korea us is number six united
states is
is consistently in the top however
however
look look at the ranking it used to be
number three yeah
so went from three to four to five to
four to seven to eight to six to eight
to six
okay so so it was a little bit higher
went to seven last year of obama went to
eight
first year of uh trump okay then uh
it uh dropped off to six then eight and
six so
that's regulation right there okay
georgia why would
uh wow look at georgia it went from 100
in 2006
to sixth and seventh place that's a big
jump that's reform right that's reform
and that's a government changing
uk uh about the same place they used to
be fourth in 2011. now it's eighth
norway uh used to be fifth now ninth
used to be eleventh so relatively around
the top ten is where they are norway
look at china where is china china's
towards the bottom of the list they're
highlighted in yellow
china highlighted in yellow thirty one
yeah used to be ninety one that one's
jumped yeah it's jump because well
because they are allowed
capitalism to take it's also moved more
towards capitalism as opposed to it has
the government communism but uh you can
build your business and do what you're
doing
yeah so then so then go all the way at
the bottom let's see what's all the way
at the bottom like what countries are my
people in kazakhstan
armenia chile italy look at italy 58th
place mexico 60th india 63 but look how
much they've come up
yeah 130. they're coming up as well uh
keep going a little lower
mario let's see what we see right there
qatar greece 79th
wow um go lower lower lower lower lower
see if
anything stands out at the bottom with
nations that we know about
guatemala mario you guys are doing good
from what's up
what are you doing in america in
guatemala
keep going brazil 124. uh argentina 126
used to be 77 so they're going the other
way around iran
about the same place yeah it's been the
same place pretty consistently not good
for business yeah
uh ecuador okay same place keep going
lower let's see what is like names that
you see
nothing nothing uh rising yeah iraq
afghanistan what is iraq 172.
okay afghanistan 173. guys breaking news
it's pretty tough to do business in
afghanistan and iraq and syria as well
if you're thinking about starting a
business there's so much
you're going to want to re reconsider
that same with that as well as down
there too
188 the worst country to do business you
surprised
our friends in somalia somalian pirates
okay go to minimum wage minimum wage
country
before we leave this can we just go to
the united states i have one question
for you to get your perspective mario go
back up to you go back to that
to ease there's a one question on the
united states so we can move on to the
next topic
top of the list top five mario top five
why would the ease of doing business the
united states
be better more between 20
2008 and 20 you know 15 2016
and then when trump comes in and gets a
little worse i thought it would be a
little
no that's different it's gone from three
four to seven eight who was president in
uh trump 2015 no no that's obama
that's obama buddy oh boom okay i got
obama raised it to seven and it hadn't
been at seven what do you mean
he was three and four his whole term it
was three before him and oh
six he doesn't get credit for three i'm
saying i'm saying
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
he was three three four he started what
year did he start what year did he start
oh wait okay what was it before he
started
three yeah okay what year was it before
he started so he doesn't get credit for
three but he took a three and he
finished it with a seven
he took a country that was third best
for business in the world and by the
time obama was done it was number seven
you're saying
from the beginning it was no you weren't
trying to make an argument you know no
i'm saying yeah it was consistent it was
between three and four the whole time
prior to it and his last term and went
to seven it was three and four
did you pay attention in math class pat
i'm looking at the freaking numbers here
it starts as a three and it's a three
the whole time is this math analysis
is this basic algebra i was a
mathematician i won the math elites i
mean i know what i'm doing here
he was a three to four the entire time
nobel prize what's funny is adam was
actually a 3.5 gpa guy
were you a three point six three point i
want to give yeah yeah three six yeah
three six
were you really yeah in college yeah
were you being serious you should have
seen mine
yeah legit legend okay so yeah if you
take a
if you start off and you're but trump
he's still doing this he's
trump is at seven through eight his
entire term but it's not like he went
backwards he went up
listen he started off with a seven yeah
when he left it was a what
six six and eight no six his last year's
assistant he went from seven
seven eight eight eight eight six
so he took a seven you don't change
rules and guidelines and all of a sudden
country
doesn't change life it's bureaucracy
be patient it takes time i see what he's
trying to say yeah i think what he's
trying to say is
if trump would have gone a second term
maybe that would have gone to three
that's a good point or third that's
that's
i'm just saying i'm shocked that obama's
numbers are that good
i thought they'd be worse obama's
numbers are terrible
what are you you're serious i
obama doesn't get credit for what what
happened in the beginning he can't
reverse things over
he was already a three prior to obama
and he kept it a three or four
what do you see he kept it out of three
or four he gets elected in oh eight
by the time he's done in his first term
it's a five by the time he's done with
his second term it's a seven
i mean you're like crashing i thought i
thought i thought
it was always okay
obama
remember when bill parcells took the
jets to the super bowl or the patriots
to the super bowl right
and they won the super bowl with bill
parcells the next year
pete carroll with the same team yeah
they didn't they didn't go to the super
bowl
pete carroll doesn't get credit for bill
parcells work
it went down that's the glasses talking
where's the glass that's the glasses
down
right the superman glasses i feel like a
tom brady cannot even defend that right
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you